Imagine we can do all system local
and give permission
for be
Finally happened just hours ago.
The successful list
of all the H-2A rocket
carrying Japan's Luna sniper.
It's a lunar lander
as well as a new X-ray
satellite telescope.
The satellite telescope,
it's called PRISM
already in Earth orbit
and will study galaxy
clusters, black holes
and the chemical makeup of the universe.
Japan's
smart lander
for investigating the moon
or Slim will
Slim will arrive in lunar orbit
in a few months
and attempt a soft landing on the moon
using high
precision
vision based navigation
landing technology.
I think that's how it gets the nickname
Moon Style.
So
joins us now
from Houston, Texas, is retired
NASA's astronaut, Leroy Chow.
Good to have you with us.
Good to be here.
Okay, so
this truly was a moment of truth
for the Japanese space program.
Three delays
to this mission, a year of setbacks
and failures
to say nothing of India's success
last month with their lunar lander.
So the pressure was really on hand
and I guess they pulled it off.
So how successful is this?
What does this mean
for the Japanese space program
and also for space travel in general?
Sure.
Well, this this is a big deal for them.
This is their first lunar probe
they're trying to launch.
They've successfully launched it,
but they're not out of the woods.
They still got to get it
to a soft landing on the moon.
So the main purpose of this mission
primarily is to actually soft
land successfully on the moon.
They do have some scientific instruments,
but the main goal was to,
you know,
establish Japan as a lunar power,
if you will. Okay.
And this is a twofer here.
This mission,
there's a new X-ray telescope.
There's also that lightweight,
high precision lander.
Which one do
you want to talk about first?
Which one?
I'm sorry?
Which one were
which one you want to talk about first?
The lander or the telescope?
Oh, well, either one.
Okay.
Let's go back to the the the lander.
Space.com says
it will take a long
looping and fuel efficient
route to the moon,
finally reaching lunar orbit
three to four months from now.
It'll be another month or so.
Before attempting a touchdown.
And that's a big shift towards
being able to land where we want
and not just where it is easy to land,
as has been the case before.
So, again,
why is this so important
when it comes to
not just exploring the moon,
but future exploration of other planets?
And just how difficult is this?
What they're trying to do here?
Well, trying to
land on the moon is not a simple task.
Only four countries have done so so far,
and there have been multiple failures
by others.
And so anyway,
this is a big deal
for Japan
to establish
that they have the technology to do this.
The fact
that they're taking a couple of months
to get there shows
that they're conserving their fuel.
But, you know,
as you mentioned, the image based,
you know, the data source
being image based is a big deal.
Because if you remember in Apollo 11,
Neil Armstrong was coming down
under the autopilot and they were
the autopilot was taking them to
a big boulder.
And he had to take manual control
and fly away from it.
And so that's kind of what
this vision landing system
is going to do.
It's going to look for the obstructions
that weren't anticipated
and hopefully be able to make adjustments
and avoid any kind of problem.
Okay.
Well,
the main payload was the x ray telescope,
which, according
to NASA, a new generation
of high resolution X-ray imaging
that will help scientists and astronomers
better study stars and galaxies,
including particles
launched at near
light speed by supermassive black holes.
At the centers of galaxies.
Can you translate what that means?
Yes.
So this is an important observatory
like all the other observatories.
They complement each other
on the kinds of data that they bring back
helps the astronomers
and the astrophysicists
put together an accurate picture
or as good as possible,
a picture of the observable universe.
So obviously,
being the x ray spectrometer,
it operates in that band,
in the X-ray band,
and so it complements
the other telescopes, the visual,
the optical ones
that actually see the same things
that we see as humans,
you know, visible light.
Also know radar astronomy.
There is infrared astronomy,
which the Webb
Telescope is really famous for,
and ultraviolet.
So I mean, there are a number
of different kinds of observatories,
and this is an important addition
to that constellation.
Just very quickly,
you know, if you know, if you listen,
if you go back in history.
President Reagan President George W Bush,
President Trump,
they've all talked about
returning to the moon,
but not just going up there
for a day
or two, but,
you know, recently
to build a colony of there
and a lot of other countries
are now interested in sending up
some kind of permanent base on the moon.
How close are we
to that becoming a reality
We're still a ways off.
I mean,
we haven't sent humans back to the moon
since 1972.
We are now starting to land
some new next generation
spacecraft on the moon.
Some of them successfully, some not.
And so it's a little bit
of a relearning process.
And so I would look to the future
and ask, of course, space X
maybe in collaboration.
This is going to be a big deal.
The moon is
kind of a stepping stone towards Mars.
So if we're serious about pushing farther
out of
the moon is an important part of that.
Leroy, great to have you with us.
Thanks so much.
Leroy Chiao there from Houston.
My pleasure. Thank you.